coming up j crawling a-a-ron tackle one
group
[Music]
more
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
mr cook you're almost up are you ready
good i'm good
okay really gonna need you to stick to
the script on this one i'm the ceo of
apple willis i'm not gonna do anything
stupid please stop comparing me to steve
jobs no but nobody's comparing you to
steve jobs okay we just want you to
focus on the products and
please stick to the script okay uh
you're on in three they're gonna forget
they ever heard the name steve jobs
[Applause]
well now the first thing that i'm gonna
do
is
t-o-t-s
throw
out
the
scripts
now
i'm supposed to come out here and tell
you about some bull
new iphone pad pod dick [ __ ] you've
seen it out of there out of there
boring
yes that's exactly it
now let's see this table right here
let's say it's bill gates huh
[Applause]
that's what i'm talking about
and let's say
that this
is our competitor's
new smartphone
[Applause]
this is one of our competitors new
e-book reader huh what about that what
uh-oh
tut-tut
looks like wayne
[Music]
[Applause]
who wants to see some of that classified
next level huh
did steve ever show you that classified
no we did you can't do that they haven't
been tested yet this device will allow
you to teleport anywhere on the planet
check this out
i
am the
future let's see steve jobs do that
well we were behind each other in line
at the grocery store and
it was silly
but i dropped a can of peas and he went
over to pick them up for me and
that's where it started
what can i say
it was love at first sight
we've been together ever since
well
yes she always
has had her own way of doing things
okay i see what's going on here honey
you don't approve of our engagement no
they're not like that i'm sorry
sweetheart yes they are like that
look at the faces
there's no point in trying to raise him
with folks
who can't appreciate the differences in
others
you should be ashamed of yourselves
honey wait
i cannot believe that you would bring a
colored man into our house
he's gone now
free at last free at last thank god
almighty we are free at last
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
next speaker the reverend robert jones
how am i supposed to follow that
i can't nobody can follow that
oh all right
good afternoon um
that is the the best speech i've ever
heard in my entire life
ever
i have never heard a better speech
and now it is my turn to speak
huh
put this running order together right
you know um dr king
uh
he actually covered a lot a lot of what
i was gonna say um you know my speech is
uh uh you're gonna find this funny y'all
my speech was actually called uh a
vision for the future
i'm not saying that dr king copied my
speech i'm
no no no
i'm saying i'm not saying that i'm not
saying he tried to copy it watch out
listen to him but i'm
wow you know what no come on i'm just
saying i'm just saying i'm just saying
it's a joke did i not say it like a joke
okay
nope
apparently i have six more minutes let's
see a red red hills of georgia he
got that out there
okay you know what all right here here's
something here's something new here's
something uh brand new how ab okay this
is off me talking off the top of my head
here everybody uh wha why how about if
we let uh black people enslave white
people for okay you know that sounded a
lot better in my head before i said it
so that's uh
that wouldn't work
is it
warm is anybody else warm
whoa
okay okay okay here's what we're gonna
do here's what we're gonna do all right
dr king talked about um uh all the races
coming together right right so what i
want every negro to do here today is
find the nearest white person and give
them a hug just just give them a hug
okay nope sir you're not being attacked
you're not being attacked you're being
hugged okay everybody take it easy here
okay everybody relax you know what we
don't need 10 negroes hugging one white
person okay let's just let's yo that's
the new rule not 10 on one one on one so
we just take turns and everything okay
so everybody relax okay oh my goodness
sir she doesn't need to be defended she
doesn't need to be finished she's okay
she's okay okay all right so man okay
officer is that necessary i don't think
that's necessary officers
please please take it easy sir everybody
take it easy all right
this is 288 i'm investigating the report
of a disturbance
[Music]
[Music]
because i got a popsicle
[Music]
oh rats whoa
watch out that black guy's got a gun
who's gonna steal your banana
what
[Music]
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go
you're gonna have to leave the area
there's been a disturbance
go for your safety sir go now please
okay go go go get going
big fuzzy god
i mean it's like it was like you know a
holiday for people having god god damn
it man is on a wall pack who's
responsible for this mess i'm sorry
chief it was me
god damn it
coffee cup my bad
anyway the last seven came out of
nowhere hey have you ever found yourself
in high porn north carolina and not
feeling safe come on down to doug
duggar's brazilian jiu
jitsu will learn to tackle on grappler
like an ultimate fighting pro
in my studio you get hands-on training
and individual attention
[Music]
tackle
take on multiple enemies
this is a tap
that's a grapple right there
this is a tackle
that's a grapple
get it there we go
[Music]
all ages learn to protect yourself and
your loved ones
[Music]
tackling
there are many different levels there's
the beginning level and if you pass my
private one-on-one sensei trial
you may make it into the advanced class
tacoma rapper the brazilian jiu jitsu at
the high point mini mall just east of
the pizza barn two doors down from
kyle's discount reels and furniture sit
quick tackle get down
uh trip him up
down there
no steak stay away
special discounts for college students
something move it get your leg down
oh thank you i wish i could just stay at
my old place but i can't afford the new
rent yeah moving sucks
you know
strangers handling your belongings the
movers always break something oh no i
can't afford professional movers i'm
moving myself to saturday
[Music]
do you think you can borrow your
roommate's band you can help me with
some of the big stuff
um
yeah
you know what
i've been thinking a lot lately and i
think we need to spend some time apart
not not to break up no i just i just
just some time
time apart to
figure ourselves out and and then and
then we come back together stronger you
know
this is coming out of nowhere no it's
not i've
i have i've tried to tell you like like
a million different ways but you don't
listen see you that's the thing is that
you you never listen i don't need this
time apart for me i need this time apart
for us how long do you think it's going
to take you to move okay this is about
the move you don't want to help me move
wha what
i want i would love to help you move
that's what boyfriends do
claire i just think that it's a weird
coincidence that you need space right
when i'm about to move oh my god
oh my god
i am so sorry that i didn't plan my
emotional turmoil around your move
look at your face see and now you've
assumed the worst of me because you do
that and that's why we need to spend
time apart from each other that is not
fair
not fair
babe all i'm asking for is 12 lousy
hours this saturday okay fine
okay fine
we'll move on sunday 48 hours i don't
know what i was thinking 12 hours
is nowhere near enough time
to do what i
need to do
to make our relationship stronger see
you got me all
confused and you know what i love you
but i got to get out of here i can't i
just can't i don't
i'm so confused right now i feel like i
can't think and the walls are closing in
on me and i just don't know what to do i
was my landlord
he says he doesn't want to lose me as a
tenant so he is not going to raise my
rent
now i don't have to leave my place
and i don't need time apart
because we're perfect together
will you marry me
[Music]
[Applause]
you paint my apartment
yeah of course i'm painting your
apartment that's what boyfriends do
when exactly do you think that's gonna
happen today on judge jesse judge jesse
turns up the heat you signed a piece of
paper he gave you the snake then you
bring a snake into the home with two
small chihuahuas i had not been made
aware that the snake would get rid of
his skin and then the sprinklers came
down with the snakeskin ruin my carpet
what what set off the sprinklers
unrelated popcorn fire your honor
judge jesse as a police officer he
defended the streets
as a trial lawyer objection he fought
for the truth
as a black belt
he mastered discipline
as a carpenter
he learned the value of craftsmanship
as a surgeon he mastered a cool head
as a crackhole
he learned to go days without sleep
and as an announcer he does the voice
over on this show
coming up on judge jesse mr simmons
before you speak i know from experience
the police have completely mishandled
your case and there's legal precedent
for you to win and any good defense
attorney would have told you that i also
know that obviously the place where you
hurt your back wasn't structurally up to
code mr oyama and furthermore as a
sensei you should know a man of his
skill set cannot do a mikeyaki you
should know that obviously i can tell by
looking at your alignment that you've
herniated a disc someplace in your l4 or
l5 i'm fighting for the plaintiff not
twenty five hundred dollars twenty seven
hundred dollars mr oyama thank you your
honor you're quite welcome
[Music]
judge jesse
dusty got a second
all right we're gonna take a little roll
here
jay cuellar
here
you are present blocky
right here uh-huh
d nice
here
good
jessica
thank you
mr garvey
what is it aaron some of us need to
leave uh a few minutes early today
oh
oh is that so
and what
pray tell
is the reason
for this premature exodus
your book photos
um
we have to leave 15 minutes early to
meet up with our clubs
all right you know what that might work
with other substitute teachers but i
taught in the inner city for over 20
years
now y'all
want to leave my class early so y'all
can go meet up at the club
ain't none of y'all old enough to go to
the damn club
ridiculous
mr garvey god son of a [ __ ]
did us
doctor just then yes
i'm gonna throw you out the goddamn
window
what jay quinlan mr garvey we're telling
the truth we we have clubs at this
school we have clubs for special
interests okay i see so y'all want to
play y'all want to play yeah okay we're
going to play little games fine i'll
play
i'm more than happy to play some games
with y'all anyone who's in a club
stand your ass up
uh-huh oh yeah there it is there it is
the usual suspects what the hell club
are you in jaquelin
future leaders of america
okay okay
how would you know
if you're gonna be a leader
in the future is there a stargate
in your bedroom can you travel through
town jay kweller no just sit the flip
down
but like i don't here's the thing i
don't even know why i'm about to ask you
this
but lockheed
what club are you in uh i'm part of the
spanish club sp this
you about as spanish as rion seacrest
with your big-ass fraggle rock hair
how about you d nice i'm in the chess
club
i'm sorry sweetheart you are
not in the chest
the mosquito bite club maybe oh it's
hurtful truthful
there he is
hey ron hey
what club
are you in
i'm the president of the glee club why
do i talk the glee club
like they don't have a club
dedicated to a tv show
take your ass to osha hennessy's office
right now before i bust a club up in
your butt okay
no okay here you go
mischievous and deceitful chicanerous
and deplorable
this is principal o'shaughnessy students
please report to the gymnasium for your
club photos fake announcement
now does anybody in here
have a valid reason for leaving this
classroom
timothy i got to go pick up my daughter
your excuse
all right listen up y'all
i'm your substitute teacher mr garvey
i taught school for 20 years in the
inner city
so don't even think about messing with
me
y'all feel me
mm-hmm okay let's take a roll here
jay quality
where's jayquillinet
no jay quellan here
yeah
uh do you mean jacqueline okay
so that's how it's gonna be
y'all wanna play
okay then
i've got my eye on you jquery
where is bolaque at
no no belake here today
yes sir
my name is blake
are you out of your goddamn mind
blake
what
do you want to go to warblucky no cause
we could go to war no i'm for real
i'm for real so you better check
yourself
d nice
is there a d nice
if one of y'all
says some silly-ass name
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath
now d nice
do you mean denise son of a [ __ ]
you say your name right right now denise
say it right denise correctly denise
right denise right
d nice that's better thank you
now
a-a-ron
where are you
where is a-a-ron right now
no a-a-ron huh
well you better be sick
dead or mute a-a-ron here
oh man
why didn't you answer me the first time
i said huh huh i'm just you know i'm
just asking you i said it like four
times so why didn't you say it the first
time i said a-a-ron
because it's pronounced aaron sonner
you done messed up hey ron now take your
ass on down to oshak hennessy's office
right now and tell him exactly what you
did
who oh shaq hennessy
principal o'shaughnessy get out of my
goddamn classroom before i break my foot
off in your ass insubordinate
and churlish
timothy present
thank you
[Music]